[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
back in January 1970 thirty year old
David kunsan was inspired by the moon
landing in the summer and so he got the
idea of walking around the world wanted
to do something adventurous so he with
his brother John began walking from
Waseca Minnesota with a pack mule they
called Willie make it to New York City
and walked all the way touch the
Atlantic Ocean then they flew across the
Atlantic to Lisbon Portugal and
continued walking from the Atlantic
coast there all the way across Europe
into the Middle East but that's when
tragedy struck on October 21st 1972 when
they were attacked by bandits in
Afghanistan that John khunts was shot
and killed David was wounded but he
decided not to give up determined to
complete the mission after recovering
from his own wounds David continued
walking now joined by a third brother
Pete on they plotted step by step across
Asia to Calcutta India where they stuck
their foot in the Indian Ocean and then
Dave alone got on a plane and flew
across the Indian Ocean to Perth on
Western Australia by this time he was on
his third mule called Willy maked and
when that one died out in the outback of
Australia a school teacher named Jenny
Samuel volunteered to tow his little
wagon with her car consequently she and
Dave fell in love and were married after
the walk ended but he continued walking
2,400 miles across Australia to Sydney
he touched the Pacific Ocean then flew
across the Pacific to Los Angeles
California Dave then walked from Newport
Beach California
back to Waseca Minnesota where he had
started becoming the first person to
walk around the earth the walk took four
years three months and 16 days Dave
walked one thousand fourteen hundred and
fifty miles crossing four continents in
13 countries wearing out 21 pairs of
shoes three donkeys and walking more
than 20 million steps this feat earned
him a place in the Guinness Book of
World Records is the first person
veritime verified to have walked the
land mass of the earth on foot you know
it takes a lot of courage to be able to
make that many steps and it takes a lot
of courage to live the Christian life
stay with his friends we're gonna learn
more about that as amazing facts brings
you this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats 1-800 four six three seventy to
ninety seven let's get to our first
bible question with pastor doug
batchelor
hello listening friends welcome to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question that's what this program is all
about you can pick up your phone now and
give us a call it is a free phone call
just dial 800 and God says 800 four six
three seven two ninety seven and I am
Doug Batchelor our regular co-host
pastor Jean Ross is on vacation today
spending some time with his sons and I'm
very pleased that we have a guest who's
been here before dr. David DeRose who is
both a practicing physician and an
ordained pastor and an author and a
radio host of another program and we're
really glad that you're here with us
tonight David great to be with you Doug
so we're gonna start the program with a
word of Prayer and then we're gonna dive
in to our devotional and some Bible
questions once again I still have a
couple of lines open that number 800 God
says 800 for six three seven two nine
seven we'll bring your call into the
studio and
we also have another number for
resources we'll give out so I have a
pencil Andy but let's pray father in
heaven we're just thankful for this
privileged opportunity to make new
friends and to study your word together
and to seek what is truth we pray that
your spirit will take charge of every
aspect of this program and bless it for
your name's sake amen amen
we know how I was thinking David that
that would you'd need to have a lot of
resolve and tenacity to walk day by day
for years and say I'm going to walk
around the world huge commitment and his
commitment was tested wasn't it that's
right yeah tested both by tragedy when
he lost his brother and that and his
health and he you know you read the book
about the man who walked around the
world he he wrote a book and it be quite
but then he fell in love along the way
and he said yeah I'm gonna finish my
commitment before I get married Wow and
so yeah and he he followed through with
it a matter of fact I think they had him
bear the Olympic torch and that was it
1996 I believe for the people in
Minnesota but maybe you'd like to know
more friends and what the Bible says
about having that kind of courage and we
have a free offer we'd like to make
available to you all you have to do is
call and ask for it it's a book we've
not offered here on the broadcast before
it's called compromise conformity and
courage how can you walk the Christian
walk in a world where we're surrounded
by
conformity and compromise and you can
still have a life of courage would you
like to know how to do that so you can
go against the flow and live for Christ
we'll send you this free book just call
and ask for compromise conformity and
courage and the number is
883 five six seven four seven that's the
resource number for the free book
tonight 800 eight three five six seven
four seven with that okay David are you
ready we're gonna try to go to the
phones and see how many calls we can get
into or maybe break a record into our
broadcast tonight all right we'll start
out talking with Mike who's calling from
Miami Florida Mike you're on the air
with Bible answers live
greeting how I
learned to ask about Matthew 25 verse
verse 14 through 30 that's the parable
of the talents King and
I'm pretty sure we're all familiar with
that so I just wanted to ask
specifically what you know I guess in a
practical sense do the talents represent
and also in verse 27 where the ruler of
those servants said that their fortune
for my money to the exchangers and then
at my coming I could have received my
month my own with usury or interest have
you even though the translations but I
want to know what the talents and the
interest like represent a practical
sense
yeah well of course it is a parable and
so there's it's filled with allegories
and allegories won't always translate
perfectly
but the talents here would represent the
things that God has given us that we can
row your mind making use of you know
education to be as useful as you can be
with your experience and your knowledge
your body using your strengths and your
health in the service of God different
people quite literally have different
talents and I think there might even be
a connection where the English word
talent comes from as it's used here in
this parable people have different
abilities that can be improved we have
time all of us have a limited amount of
time but we can invest our time in God's
kingdom so that it grows in souls that
are saved and you know for every person
you reach that person might go out and
reach to more people so it's like it has
an exponential growth and then when it
talks about the interests at the end
this unfaithful servant you just bury
the talent off in a drawer somewhere and
he said look you could have at least
you know giving it to the bankers and I
don't know the analogy there might be
just live the life even if you're not
gonna share your faith live the life and
some will be influenced by that but he
just took anything he got from the
master and just hid it the amazing thing
about the parable to me Doug is that
every one is given something and it's
interesting the one who does the poorest
is the one who's given the least so
we're not excused because we say well I
don't have the I don't have Doug
bachelor's talents so I can just you
know just sit back and put my you know
feet up and wait for Jesus to come we're
to be actively using that which God has
given us there's a similar parable in
the Book of Luke that sounds as though
it uses a little different analogy but
it sounds as though if we multiply our
talents he gives us more matter of fact
and the judgment of that parable it's
telling us that he that is faithful in
that which is least is faithful and much
it's a takeaway to talent from him who
did not invest it and give it to him who
did but to hey I hope that helps a
little Mike and we don't have
specifically a study guide on talents we
do have one on Christian finances and
that would be called in god we trust'
will be happy to send you a free copy if
you'd like that eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven for the
resource line also if you need prayer we
do have chaplains there again is 808
three five six seven four seven and if
you have a Bible question 800 God says
appreciate that Mike and we're gonna go
next to talk to caddy who's calling from
Glendale California
daddy you're on the air with Bible
answers live
I want to know about your opinion about
them being a class reunion on asaba it's
in one of the classmates homes and
everybody's Adventist I don't know I
feel bad what do you think well if if
it's being planned by Christians then
the the thing is that
you know hopefully during the day of the
reunion they will have spiritual
activities and so I would find out
what's on the agenda if they've got
activities that are appropriate for the
day of worship then getting together
with other classmates in an attitude of
worship it might be a weekend a Sabbath
weekend that I think would be fine but
if they've got activities that they're
planning and that you know maybe people
may have grown up in the church and
they've drifted and it's not going to
have a spiritual overtone well I don't
know then I'd be it may be uncomfortable
I don't know what you think yeah I mean
the text one of the texts that comes to
mind is in Isaiah 58 verse 13 if you
turn away your foot from the Sabbath
from doing your pleasure on my holy day
call the Sabbath a delight the holy day
of the Lord honorable she'll honor him
not doing your own ways nor finding your
own pleasure nor speaking your own words
and then the Lord goes on it gives that
promise but Doug exactly what you're
saying if it's something that you sense
God can bless I mean there's there's no
prohibition there but if it starts
straying into things that you would feel
are not glorifying God drawing you away
from him then that's what becomes
questionable I know Karen went to like
12 years of Christian school and they
have occasional reunions and and she'd
look and see that there they're gonna
meet in the reunion have Sabbath
services and right and I thought well
you know you can go to that and pretty
soon yeah but then sometimes they get to
get in other reunions they sort of just
whoop it up it stops becoming something
that it would be appropriate so hope
that helps a little bit caddy and we do
have a book on how do you keep the
Sabbath holy we can send you a free copy
if you call the number 800 God says how
do you keep the Sabbath holy 800 God
says that's eight hundred four six three
seven two no no I gave you the wrong
number eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven four the resource
eight three five six seven four seven
talking next to Ezra in Orlando Florida
Ezra you're on the air with Bible
answers live
taking my call absolutely my question my
question tonight has to do with polygamy
I understand it's God's ideal for one
man and one woman in marriage but I was
looking for text or some kind of clarity
on how come God never punished any of
the patriarchs or live in a polygamous
life well in a sense he did I mean look
at what happened with Abraham and Sarah
Abraham ultimately had to put Sarah away
and God's instruction
Hagar no censor Sarah encouraged Abraham
and then Abraham had to put here our way
thank you very much for catching that
and then you look at the problems Jacob
had with when he not only he didn't want
four wives he just wanted Rachel he
ended up with Rachel Leah and then in
turn they're Henry's and there was so
much fighting in the family and even a
little bit of incest happening between
his firstborn and one of this Reubens
stepmother it caused all kinds of
problems
whereas Isaac who had one wife Rebecca
he live longer than Jacob or Abraham and
it says he loved her and they seemed to
have a much happier home in that respect
so
and you know obviously God made one wife
for Adam God we did the ignorance you
know someone asked Benjamin Franklin one
time can you show me one scripture that
says a man cannot have more than one
wife he said that's easy it says no man
can serve two masters
so but you know of course throughout the
New Testament one of the criteria for
being an elder it's as husbands of one
wife
and some of wonder does that mean that
you know if a person was divorced they
could never be an elder I think it's
talking about problems with polygamy
that still existed in the Middle East
back then so you have those scriptures
in both New and Old Testament
okay so I guess in essence the family
dynamics was where they pretty much got
punished yeah look at what happened with
David with his multiple wives and
Solomon's wives drew his heart away even
though he had been loyal to God and you
know your polygamy the the fighting you
read about huh Elkanah two wives pnina
and hannah the the bitter animosity that
was in the home I mean any married man
knows that their wife is going to be
very resentful if they have another
woman in their life can you imagine
having one in the house full-time I mean
the affections aren't shared naturally
in that way and
God winked at their ignorance because it
happened a lot in polygamy but it wasn't
wasn't part of his original plan hey you
know Azra we do have a book we'll be
happy to share with you and it's dealing
with the subject of marriage divorce and
remarriage and it says a little bit
there about polygamy and we'll be happy
to give you a free copy of that thank
you for your call and we're gonna be
talking with let me see a gene calling
on light and six from Pontiac Michigan
Jeanne you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi there
how are you
alright how about we help you tonight
well I always have discussions with
various Sunday keepers about the Sabbath
of course they always want to argue with
me
all the other
the other nine are repeated in the New
Testament
good time and
they did this on the first day and it
did that on the first day so what that
means it's changed I said no and we go
back and forth
I've always felt that my answers were
adequate I never seemed to give them a
adequate answer police satisfactory to
them I mean it's obvious to me you know
so yes you're wondering is the Sabbath
command repeated in the New Testament
yeah they wanted to spelled out for them
I don't know why well yeah I've heard
that before Jean and I I appreciate that
the first thing is the question is based
on a myth they say all of the other
commandments are repeated in the New
Testament but I I would say we're in the
New Testament do you find the
commandment thou shalt not take the name
of the Lord in vain that's not in the
New Testament it's not repeated it I
mean the Lord's Prayer says hallowed be
thy name in other words these inferences
and to that but you don't find that
commandment repeated in the New
Testament so if they're gonna if they're
gonna go by that argument they need to
say that it's okay now to take God's
name in vain which of course is absurd
but I think and you may think of another
one dr. DeRose but I think that Hebrews
four it says there remains therefore I
was thinking of a Sabbath for the people
of God and
well another great example is Jesus
himself I mean resting in the tomb I
mean we might say that that's indirect
but Jesus at the end of his completed
finished work on this earth he rests in
the Sabbath just like and you could say
again that's an inference but still you
know it validates that essential truth
about the the Sabbath commandment yeah
and then of course it talks about the
the pattern of Jesus it tells us as his
custom was before yeah he entered into
the synagogue
on the Sabbath and read the scriptures
so you got the example of Christ and a
Christian is a follower of Christ and
whenever you're in doubt if you're
keeping the Ten Commandments you're
probably safe friends I don't do it to
be saved do it because you love the Lord
and it says if we love him keep his
Commandments I think and the Ten
Commandments would be just the
foundation of that gene you'd also enjoy
the new book that we just did matter
fact we have a new magazine called the
day of the Lord that is completely
dedicated to the Sabbath and it's filled
with answering questions on that subject
called the day of the Lord if you want a
free copy call 808 three five six seven
four seven we'll be happy to share that
with you and we appreciate your call by
the way that does free up another line
I'm looking and we've got two or three
lines open friends if you have a Bible
question we still have about 42 minutes
to go 800 God says brings your question
into the studio at Bible answers live
800 for six three seven two nine seven
and let me see here we're gonna talk
next to Jamie who's calling from West
Frank Illinois Jamie you're on the air
with Bible answer is live is that West
Frankfort
we're good
okay I'm looking for this and then I
come across a couple other things and I
was like man I would really like to ask
the question about that instead
so basically the question I originally
had though and it was something that I
read like I always do I thought that I
marked it and apparently I didn't
because I cannot find it
and he was basically speaking to the
Pharisees and they were challenging him
and it was I believe about death
it kind of somewhere along the lines of
you know he made the remark that you are
really mistaken and you do err not
knowing the Scriptures or the power of
God for those that are worthy to obtain
the Resurrection neither marry nor are
they given in marriage
that's what he was arguing with the
severa sees and he said they don't know
the scriptures that's where Jesus said
that
okay
but here's the god of the living
he's the God of Abraham Isaac and Jacob
is that the yeah we're the scribes and I
mean the Pharisees and the Sadducees
were were arguing the Sadducees didn't
believe in the resurrection is that the
context so what's the question about it
nowhere okay so where did you find that
thing cuz I
I think that's actually fairly late and
Matthew I'm trying to put my finger on
it real quick for you yeah it's in the
20s when he has the debate with the
scribes and the Pharisees
yeah yeah 22 I think yeah
Matthew 22
well so is does that answer your
question then
the second question you want to ask
quickly
he was saying that you know when when
Peter told them when they get to Kevin's
they will be judging on the throne and
they will be judging the 12 tribes of
Israel so is that basically meaning
because to me I take that as
judging strictly Jews or does that
basically cover all humanity that
believes in him well there first of all
the 12 apostles are not going to be
passing judgment as in condemning people
the ancient judges of Israel were
leaders that were respected and so Jesus
is telling the Apostles you'll be
sitting on Thrones like the ancient
judges of Israel eating God's people so
when he says 12:12 Israel that's I think
a.m. that's a metaphor for God's people
spiritual Israel as well as Jews and so
it's an all-encompassing
statement in first Corinthians 6 it
speaks about the Saints judging the
world so again I think this is speaking
of you know like you mentioned they're
not passing sentence so to speak but
they're validating God's righteous
judgment during what we would say is the
the Millennium yeah well we do have a
lesson that we can send you that talks
Jamie about the judgment and it's called
facing the judge it goes into more
detail about that and we'll send you a
free copy if you call 808 three five six
seven four seven and I hope you'll enjoy
that all right that takes us next to is
a Jaclyn calling on line 9 from Bismarck
North Dakota Jaclyn you're on the air
with Bible answers live
and this is chute green oh I'm sorry I
I've got a spelling impediment but
anyway so your your question
well you find that I think it's James
chapter 5 where it tells us yeah that if
there's any sick let them call for the
elders to come and to pray over them and
says if their sins are forgiven their
sins will be forgiven when you enter
into it now do you have a are they
praying for your physical healing in the
quiet you yes okay then yeah you prepare
your heart before they come and say our
Lord I want to just be available so if
you want to perform a miracle of healing
for me and I've seen it many times I've
quite literally seen people that were
diagnosed with incurable cancer we had
anointing services and and they were
healed and we've got one lady in our
church right now that they said she had
liver cancer and we had an anointing
service and she is fine and if whatever
they saw before is gone and she feels
fine so um I do believe in it but you
want to humble yourself before God
confess any known sin and say Lord I'm
willing to do your will and prepare your
heart there's a great little book called
ministry of healing and it has a whole
chapter on prayer for the sick that's
really really excellent done that time
yeah probably could read that online for
free now I think it's public domain
ministry of healing and read the chapter
called prayer for the sick and yeah yeah
and but it's biblical you know they they
don't baptize you in oil the oil is a
symbol for the Holy Spirit they usually
take a little olive oil just kind of
touch your forehead and it's a symbol of
being anointed and for healing so hey I
thank you very much for your call
jessalyn and I'm gonna talk next with
William
he's calling from New York New York
William we've got about three minutes
till the break you got a quick question
[Music]
Jeremiah chapter 29 verse 2 the size of
males and 2 kings the size of a female's
my question real quick should
hermaphrodites or the intersexed marry
people were born this way not
transgender should they marry and who
should they marry also
concerning surgery at birth that is that
moral to you I know if one is going
blind or deaf surgery to correct that
it's a good thing to do but should it be
done all right that's a good question
well tell you what you called on the
right night because we've got a medical
doctor in the studio and dr. DeRose
first of all when a person is born that
has some of the characteristics of male
and or female is it my understanding am
I correct that every person born has the
genetic makeup of either boy or girl or
is a chromosome makeup of either boy or
girl well strictly speaking you know
there's either X Y or xx but there are
some people that have
unusual genetics and there's others that
have the genetics there's an unusual
condition called testicular feminization
where someone can actually have the
genetics of a man and could develop as a
female so there are the common is that
it's very unusual so the issue is though
Doug you know we're speaking about
hermaphrodites these are people that
would have actually
characteristics of male and female this
is very very unusual
biologically were programmed to develop
as females unless there's the male
hormones so if a man's if someone is
genetically a man and doesn't those
hormones the testosterone doesn't fully
have its effect it can be confusing all
right yeah we appreciate that but it's
it might be one like one in a million so
yeah I take your doctor's advice on that
situation Bible doesn't really address
that so hope that helps a little bit
William if friends we're going to get
ready to take a break here in just a
we do have some lines open if you have a
Bible question we're getting all kinds
of interesting questions tonight you can
add to that just call in 800 God says
800 4 6 3 7 2 97 with your Bible
questions and we're gonna be back after
these announcements with more questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history or what recent world
events are harbingers of the end are you
ready for the coming crisis landmarks of
prophecy offers clear answers to your
most pressing questions presented by
pastor Doug Batchelor landmarks of
prophecy is a contemporary video Bible
study adventure designed for today's
audiences presenting the landmark themes
of the Bible and a bright and compelling
way helping you understand the Bible
better and giving you knowledge to face
the future with confluence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven now let's join pastor Doug
Batchelor for more Bible answers live
we are back live welcome listening
friends if you've joined along the way
this is Bible answers live and you can
call in with your Bible questions I
still see two phone lines open and that
number is 888-259-3826
from a story in New York welcome he
Frank you're on the air yes
you know my question is for you and a
doctor this is a question I've been
wanting to ask for a very long time I
usually read the Bible at night and I
read related scriptural books that
relate to Scripture you know there are
reading books that contain many prayers
that relate to many of the important
scriptures in the New Testament but my
question for you pastor Doug is this is
it healthy moral or ethical nature to
believe in other things besides holy
scripture because I was offered at one
time a I used to belong to an
organization that
contains certain principles that stated
that if you follow them you will be
closer to God and you will understand
Christianity and other of God's
spiritual principles much more deeper
and you will be closer to God and closer
to your fellow brethren if you follow
the the hierarchical understandings of
the organization I love the organization
I no longer belong to the organization
but they did all for me and all right
well wait I don't want to go forever
with a question here so you're wondering
is it okay it correct me if I'm wrong
you're wondering is it okay to read
supplemental material or other material
that does support the Bible
yes and and if it helps you reach to to
a better knowledge of Christ through
that
okay
you know in principle
the Bible is the foundation for what is
truth and everything must be measured by
the Bible but there's nothing in the
Bible that says you're not allowed to
read anything other than the Bible if
it's in harmony with truth now you know
you person might have to read a book to
pass the driver's test so there's all
kinds of reading people do but I know
we're talking about spiritual reading
here and so
there is obviously stuff that it tells
us in the Bible that you try the spirits
and hold fast to that which is good but
you try them by Scripture yeah and I'm
looking at 1st Thessalonians chapter 5 a
couple of very short verses they're
verses 19 and to 20 quench not the
spirit despise not prophesying --zz
prove all things hold fast that which is
good thought my biggest concern is a lot
of these things and even in in the
disciples day they said that some you
know Peter was speaking of Paul's
writings that some actually twisted them
to their own destruction a lot of people
today are twisting the Scriptures but at
the same time the Holy Spirit shines new
light on the word sometimes through a
good pastor at me through a ministry you
know like amazing facts God has blessed
me through this ministry and I know many
others so we got to test those spirits
and the test is the Word of God yeah
that's right so you just you need to
measure things and and to add to what
dr. DeRose was just saying there are
some great reformed writers like you
know everyone from Martin Luther to John
Wesley that wrote some tremendous
inspirational material there are some
great Christian writers they may not
have known everything they never claimed
to know everything and so you need to
recognize when you're reading their
writings they were men they knew they
weren't the Word of God and their
writings were not to be compared to the
Word of God and
you sometimes have to eat all the melon
and spit out the seeds and so that would
be true with other writings hey thank
you Frank we appreciate hearing back
from you and as always we're gonna talk
now to robert calling from Long Island
New York Robert you're on the air with
Bible answers live
yes greetings yes yes my question okay
now that we're in the presidential
election season and I felt that one
candidate has insulted my denomination
while another candidate has in fact
praised my denomination for their
philanthropic work and also your support
of religious freedom in the workplace
now my general question is should am I
wrong as a Christian to choose a
candidate based on that candidate
religious belief that's a great I'm glad
you asked that question you know that is
actually a very good question
do we look at a candidate's religious
beliefs when we're considering who to
vote for well of course a person's
religion and their their theology does
affect their worldview and it's you know
if a person says well I don't bring my
religion into my work well your religion
is probably not very good if it doesn't
impact who you are and your values and
morals but that said you know you if
you've got a couple of candidates that
are running if they don't happen to be
part of your particular church or don't
claim any church when it comes to like
president you're not looking for pastor
of the United States you're not
expecting that person to impose their
religion on the United States but you're
hoping that they've got values and
morals and so you know I think that you
really need to look at what they're they
they demonstrate as a pattern and
usually I think it's Solomon who says
what has been is what will be you can
usually look back and say what does
person's pattern been have they been a
good leader have they been an ethical
leader and
because people claim all kinds of
religious things you know in prison
there's a lot of people who are
genuinely converted and then there's
some people in prison who will claim
conversion to try to impress a parole
board and so you politicians do the same
thing and so you just have to use
judgment I want to elect somebody based
on their profession of religion I'd look
at the pattern and then keep in mind you
know you're not electing someone to be
pastor of the United States when it's
the presidential race I mean I think
it's it's a deeply spiritual decision I
mean the whole voting process and James
promises us in James 1 that if we lack
wisdom we can ask God and he'll he'll
basically it's a paraphrase make it
clear so as you're praying about the
candidates ask God for guidance and I
believe he'll give you the clear clear I
insight into it thank you Robert for
asking a timely question with that now
we're gonna be talking with sherry who's
calling from Cincinnati Ohio Thank You
sherry for your call you're on the air
hi how are you tonight better than we
deserve
yeah well my question is recently my
husband and I have heard some things
about it's in commandment the original
ones before they were broken being
written on
sapphire taken from God's throne and I
just wanted to get maybe some clarity or
your thoughts on that I've heard that
before
you know it does talk about a pavement
of sapphire under God's throne I was
just getting ready to look up the verse
and and didn't didn't get it I think
and some have speculated that the Ten
Commandments were written on a like blue
sapphire stone is that what you're
talking about yeah
I'd there's no scripture that I know of
that says that
it may be and
you know I'm I'm tempted to think that
the second set of stones you realize
there's two different sets the first set
of stones that God cut out of the
mountain and gave to Moses who knows
what God did to it by touching it I mean
he could have made it anything but when
Moses brokered God said cut our hue
another set of stones and bring them to
me and I'll write on them the words of
the first so we don't know I don't know
that Moses comments or the scripture
says what kind of stone it was you know
I've heard the same inference dug and
and sherry but again as far as the
scriptures it seems to me that they're
they're silent on the topic at least
from anything I've seen yeah I'm looking
at I just looked up in the word sapphire
and there there's not that many
references to exodus 20:4 10 like you
mentioned though you know had that yeah
so it could be now you know I've heard
some say when you get to the stone
foundations in the New Jerusalem you got
Greek names but one of those stones in
the fountain would have been the same as
the Sapphire pavement or under the
throne of God because the Greek and the
Hebrew names for stones are very ancient
names and there's still some question
about what those stones were you know
the other interesting aspect to it I
know we want to infuse things with with
great meaning and precious stones but in
God's work he often takes very simple
things he takes things that are common
and and gives them especially great
significance and you think about the New
Jerusalem it's got the names of the
twelve you know children of Jacob you
know twelve tribes of Israel and and
also the Twelve Apostles and they were
anything but because I'm exemplary
through much of their lives right a
matter of fact one of the the great
lessons of the whole sanctuary is here
you've got this beautiful golden
sanctuary in the middle of it you've got
us a an inner sanctum the Holy of Holies
and in that you got a golden box is the
only thing there in the box look at
these stones the simplest of things and
but they have the Word of God and that's
the important thing the Word of God is
on those stones and so you know it could
have been sapphire we actually had a
member of our church that has a business
say he cuts stone with a diamond and
lasers and he made a set of Ten
Commandments for us and I think he put
them on like a blue quartz because he
had heard the same thing interesting
questions hey thank you very much sherry
appreciate that we do have a lesson
we'll send you for free called written
in stone about the ten commandments I
don't know if it says anything about
sapphire in there but we'll send it to
you hey thank you we're gonna talk next
with Sandra who's calling from Calgary
Alberta
Sandra you're on the air with vital
answers live
the question I had was in regards to
Galatians 410 I'm wondering if it has to
do with the feast days well let me read
this year for ya go ahead are you
observe days and months and seasons and
years
yes I think that's what he's talking
about and you'll notice that Paul there
in Galatians and in Romans 14 and other
places Paul was often dealing with
Jewish Christians that were insisting
that the Gentile converts to
Christianity needed also to keep the
Jewish feast days and Sabbath's and
we're not talking about the Sabbath of
the Ten Commandments we're talking about
the you know annual holy days and the
new moons and the some of these
ceremonial holidays and
Paul was arguing he said that you know
Christ really was the fulfillment of
that no question it's it's wonderful we
don't have to be under a burdensome list
of rules and regulations I mean Jesus
has you know freed us from the the curse
of the law which is the penalty of the
law but we don't have to follow the
ceremonial laws of the Old Testament
Jesus is the fulfillment you know yeah
I'm trying to convince my husband of
that
well you know there he he's struggling
with that
no well I came out of the church that
celebrates the feasts and whatnot and my
husband is still there oh
yeah that was a controversy but I I came
across the scripture and I asked him
about it and he had a totally different
like I don't know if he just show us not
to see it and but he had a different
yeah there's that verse in the first
Corinthians 5:7 that says purge out
therefore the old leaven that you might
be a new lump as you are unleavened for
Christ is our Passover
sacrifice for us so obviously with that
Passover Jesus kept with the disciples
he completely changed what the the
meaning of it was and he showed that he
was a fulfillment of it and so um I I
think that it's a mistake for Christians
to feel they need to keep the the
ceremonial Sabbath's that obviously came
after sin whereas the Sabbath of the Ten
Commandments was part of a got the
perfect plan before sin that's right
alright and we do have a book we'll send
you a free copy Sandra it's called feast
days and Sabbath's feast days and
Sabbath's written by Joe Cruz and if you
call 800 eight three five six seven we
will send you a free copy of that
appreciate your call all right it's
going to be talking next with RC who's
driving his truck listening on satellite
radio my guess RC you're on the air with
Bible answers live
I had a discussion this past weekend
about Jay and I'm under the belief that
James is the half-brother of Jesus
your thoughts on that and is there
anything to back that up
there is a reference in in Matthew 13 we
know that Jesus did have a brother named
James I'm reading there from Matthew 13
beginning with verse 55
speaking of Jesus is this not the
carpenter's son is not his mother called
Mary and his brethren James and Joseph
and Simon and Judas so there was a
brother of Jesus and most think it was a
half-brother because of course Mary was
a virgin so there's some suggestion that
Joseph had been married previously and
this James appears to be the one who was
the author of the book of James since
the Apostle James was beheaded very
early on the book of James being written
after that yep so I believe the author
of the book of James we just did a
lengthy study on the book of James and I
believe the author was the half-brother
of or stepbrother of Jesus I
appreciate that
yeah and it's interesting that he was
converted you know the brothers of Jesus
at first were a little bit apprehensive
about Christ's claims to being the Son
of God but even though they grew up with
him they came to be believers and that's
quite a testimony because you know you
live at home with somebody for 30 years
and if they've got bad behavior you're
gonna know
and James ended up referring to his
younger brother as the Lord
so gonna lose you I'm gonna lose you I'm
driving into them out all right thanks
for waiting appreciate ya RC appreciate
your call all right that does free up
another line we still have a few minutes
left 800 God says that's for six three
seven two nine seven 800 four six three
seven two nine seven brings your call to
the studio talking to Charles calling
from Monroe Michigan Charles you're on
the air
tonight doing well we're looking
yeah I had two quick questions I needed
an answer on real fast um the first one
was on Hebrews 10:26 I believe it is
okay on willful sin I was wondering if
that was referring to us or was he
speaking to the Jews who have come into
Christianity and they reverted back to
it because the old law didn't have
forgiveness or willful sin well actually
the Lord is sending this message to
everybody he says for if we willfully
sin after we've received the knowledge
of the truth there remains no more
sacrifice for sin that would not be
exclusive to Jew or Gentile but to
believers now that we're gonna it says
sin willfully people get scared by that
and they think wow who out there
listening right now has not sinned
wilfully where you knew what you're
gonna do was wrong and you premeditated
and you sinned
if we're condemned because we committed
a willful sin we are all doomed but the
phrase there if we sin is talking it's a
verb that means ongoing if we continue
to sin willfully after we know the truth
if a person persists in high-handed
rebellion after they know what God's
will is what more can God do all they
have look forward to is fearful judgment
it doesn't mean it's right you know you
break down and you send once willfully
and then you repent of that that because
you sent willfully it's hopeless you
know I love Matthew 12 31 where Jesus
said all manner of sin and blasphemy
shall be forgiven unto men and then he
goes on to say but the sin against the
holy spirit won't and that's this
rebellious
where we refuse to listen to the Holy
Spirit's promptings but the good news
all manner of sin and blasphemy are
forgiven when we come to Jesus
that's right okay and then my second one
real quick is on
Melchizedek and uh
who who he is particularly because I've
seen some people would argue that
it's God in human form because Abraham
gave 10% to him of every table all
tonight those tithes and everything that
he had and I see some people to say that
he's just an average another man yeah
you'll find Melchizedek in the book of
Genesis where Abraham's coming back from
this battle with these kings in the
north and he gives it high of all his
bounty from the war till Melchizedek now
if that was God you know what's God
gonna do with all those sheep and
skins of grape juice and gold and
Melchizedek was a real king of a real
place it tells us where it was Salem
later known as Jerusalem and it says he
brought forth bread and wine he is a
type of Christ in that the name
melchizedek means the king of
righteousness and the fact that he was a
king of Salem means king of peace Christ
is our king of righteousness our king of
peace in the New Covenant he brought
forth bread and wine and he is our high
priest and so
you have an analogy a person who is a
type of Christ but they were a real
person now I can't prove this but one
theory I've read about is Noah had a son
named Shem that actually lived into this
time period and some have wondered if
after Abraham settled in the promised
land if Shem and his clan did not also
move and settle in the area of Salem and
Abraham paid tithes to him because he
was greater than Abraham and he meant
the man would have been taught him think
he lived in nearly 600 years he would I
might I said so one of the few people
who had lived before the time of the
flood was still alive when this happened
with Abraham so don't know if that's the
case but it's an interesting theory and
but no kids I think I believe was a real
person hey thank you for your question
on that Charles we're gonna see if we
can sneak in another call before we have
another break in we're gonna talk with
Marjorie calling from college place
Washington Marjorie you're on the air
with Bible answers live thank you please
explain Matthew 10:28 about the body and
the soul all right let me read this for
my friends out there Matthew chapter 10
verse 28 and jesus said fear not them
that kill the body but are not able to
kill the soul but rather fear him he was
able to destroy both soul and body in
hell well first of all this is an
important verse because it makes it
pretty clear that some people think well
the body is destroyed in hell but the
soul lives on and on well Jesus doesn't
say that Jesus says soul and body in
hell now you can have a body without a
soul well God made Eve Adam before he
breathed his breath of life in him he
was just a body after God breathed the
breath of life in him it says he became
a living soul that's the combined body
soul spirit consciousness when a person
is destroyed in the fires of hell it's
just that they perish soul and body is
destroyed jesus said don't be afraid of
somebody who might persecute you
physically but they can't take your soul
it's good to know that you know heaven
forbid if we should ever be tortured for
our faith the devil and his minions and
evil people can torture your body but by
God's grace they can't touch your soul
but the one you should fear is the one
who has control over soul or body in the
last days you know I'm always reminded
that
everybody's gonna have somebody mad at
them hmm you're either gonna have God
disappointed with you and the world is
gonna love you or the world's gonna love
you and God's gonna be disappointed but
you know you can't serve two masters and
he that's a friend of the world is an
enemy of God the Bible says so you just
got to make up your mind do I want to be
friends with the one who can give me
everlasting life or do I don't want to
be friends with the world for temporary
acceptance but eternal loss any thoughts
on that well I mean the Bible is very
clear the only one that has a morale in
more tality is God himself and it's not
something that we possess and you're
right it's a gift from him and he's the
one we want to align ourselves with
absolutely hey listening friends I tell
you what we do have a book that talks
about the subject of death Marjorie we
will send you a free copy of that it's
called are the dead really dead if you
call that toll free number 880 five six
seven four seven we'll send you a copy
the book are the dead really dead for
free anyone out there if you're
struggling to better understand what
happens when you die there's a lot of
confusion in the Christian world on that
subject but we all know that there's a
resurrection of the just you'll enjoy
that study are the dead really did hey
friends don't go away we got some
announcements coming on that other
amazing
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes
heroes of great deeds
great love and great sacrifice
but behind them is another hero gettin
in plain sight amid the shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light
seeing Jesus in all the Bible a new book
by Doug Batchelor
get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767
[Music]
so what is the brightest light in the
world well naturally you'd say the Sun
but we're talking about the brightest
man-made light in the world it's the
light that shines out of the roof of
that pyramid-shaped hotel in Las Vegas
called the Luxor there in the cap of
that hotel there's a room that contains
39 washing machine size xenon bulbs and
each of those bulbs requires about 7,000
watts altogether they produce about 40
billion candle power of light and
imagine getting that electric bill at
the Luxor Hotel every month that light
is so bright that planes can see it 250
miles away they're shooting light 10
miles up into space meaning if you
happen to be floating by you can read a
newspaper up there and as you might have
guessed that bright light has become the
world's best bug attractor bringing in
malls and bats and owls creating its own
ecosystem there at night above the hotel
but the sad thing about the brightest
light in the world is especially when
the night air is clear without any
particles the light doesn't hit anything
and it's invisible it shoots up into
empty space the brightest light in the
world illuminates and nothing you know
the Bible tells us that there's another
great wasted light and that's the light
of God's Word it says in psalm 119 verse
105 thy word is a lamp unto my feet and
a light unto my path and yet so many
people are walking in darkness
furthermore jesus said if you do have
that light make sure you don't put it
under a bushel but you let it shine and
illuminate the lives of others jesus
said Matthew chapter 5 set your light up
on a hill like a city so that all might
see it light only benefits others when
it reflects off of something God wants
our lights to illuminate the lives of
others so are you glowing for God
remember Jesus said let there be light
for over 50 years amazing faxes shared
the wonderful news of salvation and
provided millions of Bible resources to
people all over the world we built
churches in India proclaim God's Word in
China and have sent free Bible studies
around the globe today's program and
free resources were made possible by our
ministry partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a ministry
partner please visit our website at
amazing facts PO RG
[Music]